there were three internal candidates
were interviewed for the post and deemed
unsuitable the job was then advertised
externally
and 18 cvs were received but only mr
beshears was selected from these
external candidates
now i spoke to the bbc as people at the
bbc in the interim
and they've never heard of such a
situation where only one candidate
gets selected from what is a very
expensive process in
advertising externally can you certainly
like that
committee why it is that only one
candidate from 18
was interviewing that one candidate was
mr bashir
um i can't shed any light on that
because uh when you're running an
organization
as big and as complex as the bbc um
do you think that's right do you think
it's right there do you think it's right
that was the case that
18 cvs were received but only one i mean
presumably this wasn't like chances it's
it's pretty serious people who'd be
applying for this and only one person
granted an interview
i i really can't comment on that i mean
the person who's in charge of this i
think is is jonathan monroe the head of
news gathering then now deputy head of
news
uh uh he would be able to uh amplify
what the
the process was i i go back uh chair i i
was running the organization of 20 000
odd
plus people um you can't be across every
d
yeah but there's an this man's a known
lion who's come back through your door
and even if you found out about it
afterwards you
you you just didn't even think about
inquiring how the process actually
occurred
therefore well um i i i go back i
it's not for me to second-guess
directors or people who are running
large
departments you again i go back you
trust them
you trust them to make the judgments to
do all the soundings out that need to be
done
i read in mr macquarie's report that uh
that jonathan monroe had spoken to steve
hewlett the
the former editor of panoramas someone
who who you would
whose judgment uh you would trust but
you know they came to their own decision
about the rehiring of
of martin bashir um and as i say
it's also clear that if we knew then
what we know now
then of course he wouldn't have been
rehard